we learn by example we change by
decision we move forward with intention
yeah I mean that pretty much covers it
you know sometimes I I read things from
my own book and I don't remember them at
all because a lot of it is it just comes
in it just was very very fluid
experience but you know we certainly
learn by example you know we're set up
that way as beings you know
we grow up we learn to walk we see our
parents walk and we see them eating a
certain way we you know we learn
everything by those around us as an
example for quite a long time
the thing is the next one is trickier we
change by decision right
that's a little trickier because you
have to be conscious to make a decision
but we have moments where life sometimes
pushes you know there's something
happens in life and we go oh we make
this decision we we get this impulse
it's very strong impulse that we have to
uh make a decision and those are and we
can all find those periods of time in
our life that where we made really
important decisions
um my husband is a filmmaker he was a
director and he was a teacher at USC and
this is one of the first things he would
ask his class to you know identify a
decision that they made in their life
that was life-changing that moved them
in a New Direction so we all and and
they love it and they come up with these
things and then he shows them how this
is a great seed for a film is because
these are
and you know they're important they
happen from your heart I need to make a
decision here they're big they're
conscious
we move forward the intention is the
practice you know
we are all really worried spend a lot
waste a lot of time on worrying what
other people think of us
I I did anyway and if you're an actor
actress or like there you know do they
like me do they not like me what do I
have to do to get this job how do I have
to act to get this job you know that's
the problem that they kind of hear the
part in their head and then they go into
the audition they deliver this part that
they hear in their head that came from
the words on the page and having been on
both sides of that experience I can tell
you that 90 of the actors who come in
they don't even come in anymore they
have to film it but ninety percent of
the actors who came in for an audition
I would give the same audition it all
sounded the same way it came off the
page and hit their ear in the same way
so
um
intention is everything
when you move forward then tension an
actor moves forward like I don't I hear
that I hear The Call of the Wild I hear
the words I hear how it seems like it
wants to be played
but I'm going to intentionally ask some
questions here what could this be what
could be going on what could he be
thinking what could he be responding to
what could he want what could is the
question and then you repeat those
questions that's the intentionality in
art in acting that's intentionally what
could it be I want to discover something
that Rings true in my own heart so that
I can make a discovery because without
Discovery it's not yours but I made this
discovery now I want to play this now I
have something to offer that comes from
me and nobody else doesn't come from my
thinking of what I heard when I read the
words it comes from a discovery I asked
some questions I discovered this thing
oh I can give it that I can give myself
to that
so intentionality I intend to live a
life where I'm connected to myself I
intend to live a life with a certain
amount of Stillness in it so I can
listen to the environment and to what's
outside of myself I intend to be kind so
I'm going to practice that I intend to
help others so I'm going to make a list
of things that I can contribute to I
intend to contribute I tell actors and
others in the book because we're now
taking that to other people who want to
live a more intentional life you know
what what are your intentions you have
to look at your intentions when you make
a decision ask yourself how does this
contribute if your intention is to
contribute as a human being to help lift
the planet up a little bit then with
your decisions you ask yourself how does
this contribute does this contribute
does this thing that I'm doing
contribute to my health to my family to
my community to the World At Large does
a contribute that's a great great
intention is to
walk forward with asking yourself you
know I want to contribute how do I
contribute how do I make the right
decisions how do I become the best
person I can be it's that simple imagine
if we were taught as little children
your job is to become the best person
you can be not your job is to learn what
date the you know war of two Savages
happened I can't even think of the wars
you know what I mean I it doesn't stick
doesn't stick who needs that nobody
needs that what we need are people
there's there's something magic about
autonomy
autonomy is being able to move forward
with self and that happens because you
have gotten to a place in your life
where you say I trust my intentions
I've been intentional enough to know
that I trust my intentions so I can't
really spend I'm not going to spend time
worrying about whether somebody likes me
or not because my intentions are correct
I intend as a teacher to see the best in
every student I you know in life could I
say I like this one better than that one
you know maybe but as a teacher no
there's no I like him I don't like him
he's in the room he's come to me for
help I intend to listen I intend to help
as best as I can I intend to help them
be as good as they can be so this
intentionality is is really the way to
move forward in life but you have to
know in what direction you have to have
the questions before that which is what
do I want to do you know and then does
it contribute
and then I'm going to intend to live a
life and now my choices is does this
intention help that along or does this
intention not help that a lot I mean I
always choose the path that helps along
my desire to uh to be the best human
being I can be
I I you know if I had another life
I would have a school I would have a
school I would have I would teach people
from a very young age to you know like
you know what is it you want to do and
and uh how to become the best people
that they can be isn't that was it's
pretty simple isn't that what it should
be all about I think that's pretty
simple
so many things I want to talk about here
but I know you think you've said in the
book that you loved acting but you
didn't like the the job of acting and
and the the auditions and and maybe the
rejection but you knew you wanted to
help people you felt you did have a
calling as a teacher
what if you have students that come in
and they say you know what my intention
is pretty pure and clear and I want to
make projects or be part of projects
that you know expose the greater good or
enable people to see things in a new
light but they're hitting like a
roadblock and they don't know why so
their intention seems pretty pure it's
not just to have a certain amount of
followers or whatever that'd be nice but
but they're they're hitting this
roadblock what do you tell them they're
maybe they're not booking roles maybe
the cast that they got together it fell
apart yeah there's no real one answer to
that because there's so many different
ways it could be blocked you know what
you're talking about is I have an
intention I think the intention is you
know a valuable intention
um I've lined certain things up behind
it and it's not I'm blocked it's not
working so you know in that case you
have to look at a holistically at the
actor you know how is their thinking are
they really entertaining a lot of
negative thinking a lot of self-judgment
do they have a perfectionism syndrome
there's a lot of different ways to even
though your intention is pure you have
to clear up some bad personal habits of
presentation it could be that you know
what I mean but the the basis is to give
them the tools to examine things very
clearly and you know they want help so
you know if you ask things like you know
are you being are you judgmental are you
hard on you oh yeah I'm really hard on
myself or you know and I say are you
hard on others no I'm not I'm not so
hard on others I'm just hard on myself
you know it makes me better you know
they think it makes them better it
doesn't make you any better it's just
judgment and by the way I always tell
them hard on self hard on others hand in
hand so you may recognize one more than
the other but I'm sorry to tell you you
know you're judgment judging yourself
you're judging others and exactly
nothing will come of that except some
false slightly stomach turning sense of
false security